I remember hearing that on job
interviews you should always try to make
your weaknesses seem like a strength by
using the magic words I'm a
perfectionist but at its core
perfectionism can truly be detrimental
because it can stop you from doing the
thing that you want to do out of fear of
failing so if you struggle with
self-doubt or imposter syndrome know
that these emotions are completely
normal
courage is not the absence of fear but
rather the ability to move forward and
take action in spite of the fear so if
you've screwed things up and have made
mistakes you've learned one way to not
do it again congratulate yourself for
the lessons learned and get back at it
again